have you ever faked an orgasm oh my god
um yes i'm thinking of any girl who says
that they haven't they're completely
lying
yeah sorry my dad
[Music]
would you ever date a man less
successful than you have you ever
ghosted anyone does jealousy turn you on
am i good at dating i'm good at teaching
others how to date
i'm not really like a data i recently
broke up with like my long-term
boyfriend probably about like six months
ago and then yeah i haven't really
done the dating thing i've been single
for roughly eight years the nature of my
work means that i've got to be going out
a lot and meeting women do you have any
big no-nos is there anything that would
be a total deal breaker i definitely
think
someone who's a bit of a game player
hello hi faye how are you so pleased to
meet you
nice to meet you as well
um so oh okay so my first question is
have you ever ghosted anyone yes
okay so the reason i asked that
is because
it's a bit of a litmus test
for if someone's a good communicator or
not would you agree 100
so why would you so you admitting that
you're not a good communicator
i haven't i haven't i haven't done that
for at least three years
the thought in my mind was like what
message could i possibly send
isn't this the kindest way to end it
right because otherwise you're saying
hey uh
like it was so nice being around you but
you know it's me not you and like for me
receiving that message is just like
really yeah and so that was my
experience but i think in the last two
or three years
i've just learned that the best way to
end something is just to be completely
honest about the situation honesty is
the best policy yeah and i feel like
it's it's like a plaster which i mean
you just
it's not a nice message to receive but
then at least it's like overdone with
there's not this like prolonged period
of
wondering yeah have you would you um
ghost a guy i've never done it but then
again like i'm not really a big
like dater
oh no
have you ever faked an orgasm oh my god
um yes i think if any girl who says that
they haven't they're completely lying
yeah sorry dad was that to get
it
over more quickly because you weren't
enjoying it or was it to protect his ego
because he wasn't performing both
we're not talking about a single
occasion man this isn't multiple yeah no
both so what what is that because like
why
would you not in that situation
just like tell him
what you like or if you're just not into
it just say like i'm not into it
do you know what like i think i wouldn't
do it anymore that is very much a so
you're a pastor orgasm faker and not a
person yeah an ex orgasm faker i love
that um i think i probably just wasn't
as confident in myself
whereas like now i'm a lot more
confident in myself and yeah i've been
quite brutal sometimes so
yeah no i wouldn't really so you mean
brutal you mean just like telling a guy
like yeah
yeah
yeah
two millimeters to the left
next question
oh my god i get to ask you if i faked an
august okay you know i think i actually
have well
i would really think we just i don't
actually remember okay the exact
experience but i have a memory
of doing so okay
as i i faked it because it wasn't gonna
happen is it any different for
a man because i imagine that would be
quite hard to fake
yeah it's it's quite uncomfortable
because it should be quite obvious sure
yeah so i think it's a sort of a
different a different game yeah
does jealousy turn you on oh god um okay
if you want some more context like yeah
yeah no gameplay
and he
maybe another girl comes and flirts with
him and he doesn't
like turn her away but he's not like
fully in it but he's talking to her
would that make you feel more attracted
to him to see him like flirting with
another girl absolutely not
if a girl came up to them i'd be like oh
that's that's nice like clearly they're
attractive enough to get attention
whatever but then i would be a lot more
attracted to them if then they set the
boundary and just like made it clear
that that wasn't something that they
were
interested in yeah would you ever like
talk to um the guy and say like you can
go and flirt with her would that be
would that turn you on like just the
idea if you're kind of in control but
you see him flirting with another girl
i feel like there's other ways to
turn you on
um
yeah
like there's i think that's just
wouldn't be something that's attractive
to me like i think people maybe have
that intention to make it a bit more
like fiery whatever
but it ends up potentially could end up
hurting someone even if you don't
anticipate it hurting someone would that
be something that you would like
like i i like kind of um
playing games with respect right so like
for example if i was dating someone and
they were like okay we can go let's go
um flirt with other people if that was
within the like framework i think
they're two extremes yeah i think that
one end of the spectrum is being like
you can't go out and see your friends
you can't do this you're just spending
all your time with me like putting your
foot down kind of thing and then the
other end of the spectrum is like going
out and floating with other people like
i think there's a there's a happy
medium
okay um this is a really good one and
the reason i'm asking it is because
myself and my friends and my friends um
boyfriends basically all had this
conversation together
would you take a male contraceptive pill
no
oh
would you want to elaborate
i don't like putting things in my body
that i don't trust 100
okay
if it was like a new pill i'd need all
the evidence in the world to make me
take a pill and know that there were no
like side effects like yeah down the
line you know do you understand that
obviously like girls go can sometimes
like go through like a lot when it comes
to
birth control so like would you expect
someone that you're with to be on birth
control
honestly i'd much prefer that they
weren't okay i've been with a girl
before like who
had like
double d's and she took birth control
and
like her boobs got bigger and then just
went soft and never went back
okay and like that's not a problem for
me obviously yeah but for her
that's a little bit traumatic so i know
that the the birth control can sort of
manipulate
women's bodies in a certain way and for
that reason i wouldn't expect any woman
to go on there yeah i think it kind of
changes your hormones
a bit as well yeah um so
yeah the thing is i wouldn't want to
talk down on like birth control like
birth control is like you know one of
the
great inventions of the 20th century but
yeah like i think it's important to
maybe recognize that like the burden
kind of
falls predominantly on women i don't
think that's fair right yeah and i think
women should know exactly what they're
getting into
would you ever date a man less
successful than you oh my god yeah but
then i think there's nothing wrong with
that the reverse of that is would you be
intimidated if a woman was more
successful than you
yeah
i don't think intimidated i don't think
as a man i would feel like comfortable
being with a woman who's like more
powerful than me okay i don't think i
feel comfortable
okay i like i appreciate you your
honesty
but i really disagree
just because i
the thing is like
i
i've definitely been in in relationships
where someone's kind of had the same
opinion as you and it's almost like
dragged me down and made me feel like i
can't
succeed yeah that makes a lot of sense
it just because they're more successful
than you doesn't take away the ability
to care for someone and the ability to
like show someone
that you care and do nice things for
them you're probably right
i've never been in a situation so i
don't know
do you know what like he's actually a
very attractive boy and so so so lovely
so so polite but i think there's
definitely
not red flags i'd say probably some like
yellow flags just popping up well she's
beautiful she's charming i feel like she
does want a long-term relationship and i
think she won't have any trouble finding
it
would you like to go on another date
yeah
oh that's really kind beautiful thing oh
thank you welcome you don't have to say
yes now by the way no i think um i think
if i'm gonna be completely honest i
think we would really struggle
the good relationships in my life have
been where i've felt that they're just
gonna like raise me up and make me do
better
and i think if it was to go any further
with you i think that would be a
roadblock interesting yeah did you think
that there was like some nuance there in
the it's not that i would want you to be
less successful than me
but i think it's like a slippery slope
and i don't think it's
something that i would want to so you
don't want to slide down you don't want
to go on another date with me
oh you look really happy
i would say no i'm sorry
did you feel like that date went well
there for you well it wasn't the most
romantic we didn't have the ambient
lighting and the red wine that would
have made it feel you know
um i suppose romantic but it was it's
cool you i could tell that she's a
you know she's
she's got a great personality and she's
a beautiful girl so i would have liked
to see her again i don't think that if i
saw her again five years down the line
the two of us are gonna be married
with dogs and and things
um children even but i i think she's
cool you know she's a cool girl and so
for me that's that's all it takes to
want to see someone again right
he was so lovely um but yeah i just
think it probably wouldn't work
what if i told you that he was a dating
coach in his day job
stop
stop it
no way
oh my god
oh
um
that was really interesting
good for him
you know he was honest and
i got to know what it would be like to
be with him but oh my god he's a dating
coach that's so interesting
what's your body count
so for me you know it's very much it
goes back to that old adage
quality not quantity okay you don't want
to say what number